Speaker 1: In the wake of the finding by a
New York jury that Donald Trump is liable
for sexual assault and defamation against writer
Jean Carroll in that Bergdorf Goodman department
store in New York City in the 1990s. We now
have a cascade of serial sexual harassment
allegations against Donald Trump from a former
staffer while he was. President of the United
States. There was maybe the the belief I don't
know. I mean, you know, sometimes it's like these
serial harassers and assaulters. They don't
often stop, particularly not when they're
in positions of power. But there were dozens
of allegations of different levels of sexual
assault against Trump from sort of like verbal
harassment all the way up to rape. Dozens of them
in periods of time before Donald Trump
became president of the United States.
A former staffer is now accusing Trump of
sexual harassment in the White House. Newsweek
reports staffers who worked in Trump's White
House have accused him of sexual harassment.
The. Okay, so a lot of this news is about the
verdict that we've already talked about and
Trump's reaction. Discussing the verdict on CNN,
Alyssa Farah Griffin, who quit as Trump's White
House comms director in December of 2020, said
Trump had a pattern of behaving inappropriately
with women while in the White House. She noted
she wasn't the only one to report such behavior to
Trump's chief of staff. Take a look at this clip
from CNN. Stunning, but not altogether surprising.
Speaker 4: If and when Donald Trump
tells you who he is, believe him.
I mean, that is this is it. We wanted to chalk it
up to locker room talk in 2016. It was not locker
room talk. Now he is credibly. He has been.
He's now been charged with or I should say,
held liable in this case for actually committing
sexual assault. I cannot underscore that enough
that your guest before made an incredibly
important point. Any man or woman who was
falsely accused would be the first person to show
up and defend themselves in a rape allegation or a
sexual assault allegation. He couldn't be bothered
to show up. I have countless cases of what I
considered impropriety in the White House that I
brought to the chief of staff because I thought
the way he engaged with women was dangerous. This
is I mean, we know these facts. The patterns have
laid out. And now this is something that's not
just speculation. It's not just allegations. It
is a jury of his peers deciding that he did this.
Speaker 2: Well, you brought to Mark Meadows,
the chief of staff or other chiefs of
staff incidents that you witnessed of
Donald Trump behaving inappropriately with women.
Speaker 4: I did, as well as former White House
Press Secretary Stephanie Grisham and others.
Nothing that rises to this level but things
that I would consider improper and that I had
a duty to report. And this is all out there.
Voters need to pay attention, and folks in my own
party need to stop making apologies for this man.
Speaker 2: Is there anything
more you can tell us about this?
Speaker 4: I, i if I'm able to, I will share more.
Speaker 2: All right. You have to come
on this show to tell us how it was.
Speaker 1: Those are major, major allegations.
Now, I want to zoom out a little bit. The broader
story with these major allegations against Trump
follows this pattern. We hear one allegation
and the MAGA rallies around Trump, and most
Republicans do, and say it's made up. And then
we get more allegations that now start to become
a pattern and it becomes much more difficult to
say that it's made up. I'll give you an example.
CASSIDY Hutchinson testified to the January
6th Committee when Democrats still controlled
the House before January of this year. CASSIDY
Hutchinson testified Trump lunged at a Secret
Service agent and demanded that he be brought.
I don't even remember where it was, where his
the rioters were or whatever. And the reaction
was, that's so out of character for Trump. Trump
would never do that. Trump doesn't have a temper
now. It's all it's all very clearly made up. And
then a couple of weeks ago, we get yet another
story, a recent one, which we have on a recording,
which is Trump lunged at a reporter on his plane
because the reporter was asking Trump questions
that Trump did not want to answer. And Trump
snatched the guy's phone out of his hand and
tossed it. Oh, so it's the exact same pattern of
lunging at people when they are talking to you
about something you don't want to talk about or
telling you something that you don't want to hear.
It starts to become more and more difficult to
deny these things, particularly when they're
recorded. So now we have another version of
this. Trump sexually harassed 1 to 25, 30,
40 women before Trump became president. It's all
fake. It's totally out of character. Okay. We now
have a court finding. A jury has found Trump is
liable for sexual assault and then defaming the
woman who accused him of the sexual assault. He
owes her $5 million. Oh, well, that's also B.S.
And now a former staffers. Oh, by the way, the
exact same pattern that Jean Carroll alleged
from the 1990s. Dozens of other women alleged
during the 2000s. It didn't stop when Trump
was in the White House. It's all the same story.
And so the right the MAGA right. Some Republicans
who continue to defend this guy, this guy will
insist these are just these allegations are so
hard to believe. They're just so random. They're
being made up. They're being weaponized. These
allegations of Trump's temper, Trump's snapping
at people, lunging at people, sexually harassing,
sexually assaulting and going beyond that with
women. It's a decades long pattern. It's a decades
long pattern that goes back. One of Trump's former
wives. I now forget which one I think it was,
Ivana said. Trump sexually assaulted her
multiple times. How can it all be this
concerted effort to defame Trump when first a
jury quite literally found that it was actually
Trump who did the defamation? And it's the same
stories from women who don't even know each other,
who have nothing. To Alyssa Farah Griffin And what
she observed when she worked for Trump a few years
ago has nothing to do with what happened to Jean
Carroll or what Trump's ex-wife alleged or what,
you know, the young women from the Miss whatever
pageant where Trump would go backstage. It's all
unrelated individuals who don't know each other.
And the pattern that's emerging is these stories
seem to be corroborated again and again and
again from unrelated sources. That's really the
revelation here. So tonight, there is a town hall
on CNN. Is it going to be handled responsibly? Is
it going to be handled the way it should be
handled, given the insanity of who Trump is
and has become? I'm not confident, but we're going
to talk about that after the break. Make sure you
subscribe to the YouTube channel YouTube.com slash
The David Pakman Show. Make sure you're following
us on Tik Tok for the short form content and
make sure you've signed up. Join Pacman dot com.